(robot whirring)
(bright pop music)
- [Narrator] Kuri is a
home robot that responds
to your voice and touch.
He can play music,
navigate around your house,
and record video, but most importantly,
he wants to be your friend.
- I don't foresee myself becoming
like super close with Kuri
- I can definitely get
attached to a robot.
Why, I'm not a very
social person, you know,
like my best friend's are three cats.
- Alright, I'm ready to meet Kuri.
- Please, bring it on.
It's just, look I'm shaking right now.
- Hi, I'm Jen. I work with
the team that developed Kuri
over in California and he's
an adorable home robot.
Let's get Kuri in here.
(laughing)
Let's go play with Kuri.
- Alright Kuri, welcome to
Buzzfeed. Let's have some fun.
We're here at my desk and we have Vanessa.
Vanessa, come meet Kuri.
He's coming. Oh...shit.
- So let's go take a walk
around with my little new buddy.
He follows you around.
- That's creepy.
(laughing)
(gasping)
- Did you hear that?
(Kuri sneezing)
- I love it so much.
- He literally has fans right now.
Are they bothering you? No?
That's totally fine, okay!
- Alright guys, what do
you think about Kuri?
- I love him.
- Okay, he's like the nicest person ever.
I don't need any of these creatures here.
What a waste, what a waste of time.
- Hey Kuri, I know that
you don't speak English
but tell me a joke.
(beeps)
Holy shit, that was funny.
He's laughing at his own joke!
- Hey Kuri, you wanna go
like try to find a wig?
I think it's gonna suit you.
That silence is like...don't
even try, bitch.
(Kuri sneezing)
Oh I'm so sorry! He's allergic to me.
(laughing)
- And for Kuri's last trick,
hey Kuri, play me your favorite song.
(robotic music)
♪ Pancake robot is coming to town ♪
♪ He's mixing up the batter
and he's laying it down ♪
♪ Buttermilk, blueberry, chocolate chip ♪
- What is that song?
- Pancake robot, ever heart of it?
- He's getting ready to leave.
This is a sad moment, guys.
I'm just not sure I'm ready for this
but you gotta get the strength and do it.
If there's one thing I
learned it's that he gets
all the attention, yo, that's messed up.
It's like walking around
with a prettier friend
and you like the shit no one looks at.
- Kuri and I had a really,
really nice day together
but eventually, he had to
go and it was pretty sad.
- Really, I did not expect to
have so much fun with a robot.
- I was super skeptical of Kuri
and hanging out with a robot all day.
- It was insane; I felt like
walking with a tiny celebrity.
- I think Kuri's so
cute; he doesn't really
do a whole lot of stuff but I like it
because I think if he knew too much,
I'd be like super freaked out.
- I'm not bullshitting you here,
I think by this time he
and I are best friends.
- Hey Kuri, I love you.
- And I'm only waiting for you
to come back so please do so.
(robot whirring)
(bright pop music)